Jérémy ça vous challenge davantage de
savoir qu'il y a trois grands chefs qui
vont être dans un restaurant à côté
c'est pas n'importe qui ils ont du
talent ça fait longtemps très longtemps
qu'ils ont peur des restaurants pourquoi
très longtemps quand je dis très
longtemps ça me dit peut-être même has
been
ah ouais je sais pas si parler que de
toi
30 cm carré pas un berger dénoncé
conditions d'hébergement dans un rap
deux place pour se relever
avec le retour du loup ses cabanes
d'urgence ont été installés à 2400
mètres d'altitude un abri que Félix doit
partager avec une autre bergère pour
veiller sur les troupeaux de brebis dans
une niche elle vient de souffler 88
bougies sous Miko est probablement la
plus vieille DJ du monde lunettes de
soleil reste en fourrure elle est la
star de la soirée vive soumis vive
soumis
quand elle est au platine c'est elle qui
mène la danse
depuis 20 ans elle mixe dans ce club de
Tokyo Robert ou lolita zeppen gothique
viennent danser toute la nuit le Parc
National de la Vanoise visée dans les
paroles à réagi il reconnait que la
solution est temporaire et que les
cabanes sont spartiate de nouveaux
modèles plus spacieux et plus
confortables sont à l'étude
la musique a pas mal de vertus pour les
enfants pour les bébés
or plus un bébé a été exposé à de la
musique dans le ventre de sa maman plus
il sera sensible après sa naissance ça
c'est prouvé il y a pas de débat or
comment faire écouter de la musique à
son foetus on peut soit allumer sa radio
ce qui est classique donc le coller près
du ventre et puis imaginez qu'il va
entendre Vivaldi parce qu'elle a priori
on fait comme ça soit utilisé cette
belle invention le Baby pod un objet qui
permet de faire écouter de la musique
par le vagin hier encore
j'avais 20 ans je caressais le temps
hier encore il était impensable
qu'Emmanuel Macron chante comme Charles
Aznavour sans compter sur mes jours qui
fuyait dans le temps désormais c'est
possible avec l'intelligence
artificielle avec cette reprise
improbable c'est ingénieur informatique
impressionne bon nombre d'internautes
[Musique]
autour de moi et j'ai gâché ma vie et
mes jeunes années concrètement regardez
vous avez une sorte de gros écouteurs
que vous allez placer dans le la maman
va appuyer sur play et là
vous aurez donc une ambiance interne une
musique
Charlotte on aime bien écouter pierre de
merde moi j'adore ou pierre de mer il
chante un jour je marierai un trois
un ours
[Musique]
regardez ça se passe aux États-Unis en
Virginie
occidentale c'est la rencontre en train
d'ours et le directeur d'un
établissement qui voulait jeter ses
poubelles je vous laisse regarder
[Rires]
ça doit surprendre c'est surprenant
beaucoup de frayeurs bon il y a pas eu
de mal hein des deux côtés mais on se
demande quand même qui des deux a été le
plus effrayant le cours de son côté
quand même ces trois petits oursons qui
viennent de naître au parc animalier
planète sauvage elle s'est près de
Nantes Chana regardez comme c'est mignon
c'est trop mignon en fait c'est deux
mâles Chuck et coda et une femelle
gaufrette alors les trois nouveaux
pensionnaires ont rejoint la pleine
américaine du parc et maintenant il
crapahute avec le reste du groupe des
ours et un troupeau un troupeau de bison
de bois alors c'est mignon mais ça quand
même des griffes assez impressionnantes
il a regardé de près le pelage du
paresseux et il s'est aperçu que c'était
un monde en soi que au milieu des poils
il y avait de la vie des insectes des
mythes des algues et tout ce petit monde
cohabite vous avez plus du tout envie de
leur faire des caresses des câlins
j'aime pas les mouches les mouches à
caca en fait ça c'est un peu une mouche
à caca les grosses mouches bref pardon
excusez-moi
puis
s'agissait d'un banal contrôle de
vitesse pour ce policier américain quand
soudain
une voiture hors de contrôle les
percutes de plein fouet
fauchées le policier se relève
immédiatement et appelle les secours
voilà bonjour donc mes collègues vous
ont expliqué pourquoi du contrôle c'est
ça refus de priorité piéton qui est
régulièrement engagé dans la traversée
d'une chaussée
sauf que la verbalisation elle arrive
monsieur
[Rires]
est censé tout changer
je peux passer tant qu'il clignote c'est
ce que j'ai compris exactement après
avoir été vers le petit bonhomme
clignote jaune les piétons engagés
continuent de traverser mais les autres
doivent attendre plus compliqué imaginez
vous êtes toujours sur ce skatepark vous
avez des rollers vous êtes je sais pas
moi au pif Laurent Wauquiez le président
de la Région Rhône-Alpes toujours prêt
pour le buzz vous inaugurez un skatepark
en Auvergne il y a des caméras vous y
allez ou pas c'est la journée mondiale
du jardinage nu ce samedi
mondiale
alors
effectivement on pourra bécher tailler
arroser dans le plus simple appareil
chaque jour est une fête
vous lancez ou pas sur le skatepark
Raiponce non vous n'y allez pas pourquoi
car non seulement vous allez vous casser
la gueule et en plus vous allez être
filmé
bah lui il est allé